So welcome, everyone,
to our session
on "Getting the Most
Out of Faculty and Staff
Partnerships."
We're delighted to have you
here at the HILT Conference
in general and at this
session in particular.
My colleague, Lisa Brem,
has worked very hard
on organizing this.
And it's great to have you here.
I think we're going to
do some good work today.
The idea behind the
session is basically
to bring faculty and staff
together and think about ways
to work together,
as a partnership
would suggest, to
figure out if you're
someone, whether on the
faculty side or the staff side,
who often works with the
other side of the table,
how you can work
more effectively;
if you think you already do work
effectively, just to give you
a space to step back
and theorize in some way
why it does work well so that
on those rare occasions when you
feel like a partnership
has been less fulfilling,
you can figure out how
and how to improve that.
If, on the other hand,
you're someone on one
or the other side of this
table who is wondering,
"Why don't faculty
come visit me?
I have amazing handouts."
Or on the faculty side, if
you're thinking, "Gosh, yeah,
I'd love to take my students
to the museum, to the library,
to do something with my Canvas
site to start using clickers,"
any of these things, and
you don't know where to go,
and it's hard to figure out
how to ask or who to ask,
or you're worried about, well
I don't want to ask the wrong
question that will, in some
way, make this a transactional
relationship rather than
a transformational one--
to borrow the dean of the
college's favorite opposition--
this session is
for you, to think
about ways in which you can
work together effectively
on the staff and faculty side.
So we have a great crew who's
sitting around me at this table
here--
Esme, Sheryl, Dan, Lisa.
Everyone can say
a little bit more,
maybe, about themselves as they
stand up to do the round table
part of the session.
But we represent, in
a sense, two examples
of ways in which a teaching and
learning center and a faculty
member or faculty team
have worked together
to do an interesting project.
So we're going to share--
let me go forward the agenda--
a couple of quick thoughts
in the panel discussion
part about things
that we've learned
about when we worked
well together,
how we can work better
together, to give you--
to see the discussion
in some way,
to think about how
you can work better.
And then, we'll give
you an opportunity
with that worksheet
that's on your table
to design your own
partnership, in a sense.
One of our goals
for this session--
we think it's really important
that both sides, again,
of this-- these
partnerships remember
that the students really are the
ultimate goal, that you should
be gazing together
at the students
and not just gazing
at each other.
And also, it's really
important that you
have clarity around your
roles, that you understand
what you as a
teaching and learning
center, as a library, what
have you really offer.
Because students will
seek out skills and try
to learn things and try to have
experiences, whether or not
we are here.
And so the thing
is to figure out
what you as a particular
center or department
have to offer them that
does not, in some way,
replace or fill a need
100% but actually amplifies
things that faculty and
students already want to do.
On the faculty side,
it's important too.
Faculty do not spend a lot of
time thinking about themselves
as project managers,
unless, maybe, they
have experience directing a
center or something like that.
So just really think about what
they want for their students
and what it would
take to get that done
and how to work productively
with a staff member who may,
at least temporarily, want you
to be a little bit of a project
manager.
So it's to help you think
about clarity in those roles
and how you can really explain
to the other side what you can
do well and have a partnership
which, again, both of you
learn from.
And it's not just,
I have a problem.
Here's a handout.
And with that, let me turn it
over to our first successful
partnership.
Lisa, you can introduce
your copanelists
and talk about what
you've learned.
Sure.
Hi, I'm Lisa Brem, and I
work at Harvard Law School.
And I am the manager of
the Teaching, Learning,
and Curriculum Solutions Group.
And what we do is everything--
it's completely soup to nuts.
It's a small,
tightly focused group
that really tries to support
faculty in everything that they
would like to do around
teaching and learning,
from clickers to talking
through discussion boards--
uses thereof in Canvas or not--
all the way through more complex
and difficult, long-term types
of projects.
So when I started
thinking about this panel
discussion and this
session, I started
thinking-- the first image that
came to mind was the pit crew.
So let's talk about the
pit crew for a minute.
This is the first image.
We were going to have
this as our image.
And it's one possible
relationship.
It's one possible
type of partnership
where people are very focused.
It's transactional.
It's fast.
It's efficient.
Everybody has
their discrete job,
and the faculty is
in the driver's seat.
And off they go to perform
what they are great at.
And that is one
way that we work.
But then, when we
were talking to Adam,
we talked about the caddy.
So let's look at the
caddy again for a second.
So this is the caddy.
And the caddy is
standing sort of
behind the golfer with the bags.
And for people-- how
many people know golf?
OK, this is a good--
thank goodness.
[LAUGHTER]
So I don't know golf that well.
But I do know that the caddy
has a lot of expertise.
The caddy isn't just like
the sherpa of the golf clubs.
They actually are able
to tell the golfer,
this is the-- you want
to use the three iron.
Is there a three iron?
Or the eight wood
or whatever it is.
Because that's going to
do the best job for you
in this particular goal.
What is it about this
relationship that's
different from the pit crew
is that it's more long-term.
It's more bespoke.
It pivots.
It is a lot more unique
to each situation
and responsive to
each situation.
So like Adam was saying,
instead of a packaged good,
you're getting a real
one-on-one relationship
that takes into account the
fact that every time you
step in front of a classroom
it's a unique situation.
So there are similarities to
both types of partnerships.
And one thing that I think
is very important to both
is trust.
So you really trust
that pit crew.
You don't want that
technology that you've said
is going to be great to fail,
because that will surely
get rid of trust really fast.
You want the faculty
and your partners
to really feel as though
you have some value
in this relationship.
And the value that
you bring is going
to be really worth
having this relationship.
So I started thinking
about the similarities
and the differences--
that we all share goals,
whether this is transactional
or a more long-term project,
and that they rely on the
knowledge and the skills
and the experience
of both parties.
So when we think about
the projects today,
certainly the products today
are-- that we are talking about
are definitely in
the caddy variety,
the long-term, more
complex type of projects.
I like to think about, what
are our goals for this project?
Can we clearly articulate
them from the beginning?
What is the value that
we bring from both sides?
If you think about,
what kind of value
would you like to
have when you're
sitting in a partnership?
What would you like the other
person to bring to the table?
And maybe even imagine something
that you've never felt or seen
before, some kind of
skill set or knowledge
that maybe you didn't even
know existed out there.
But maybe it would be
really great to have it.
So if you could imagine
what that might be.
And, also, how can we measure
the success of these projects?
I think that's such
an important question,
and it's one that we don't ask
early enough or often enough.
So how would you
describe success?
Is it OK to iterate for success?
Is it OK to fail
moving towards success?
And is it OK-- is there a
place for sure experimentation?
Does everything have to fit
into the organizational goals?
Does everything have to be
efficient or be replicable?
So where is that space
for experimentation?
How much of that space
do we have in the life--
in the daily work that we do?
So those are all the things
I started to think about
as we talked about how to create
a session around partnerships
and I'm going to turn it over t
I'm so grateful to have Sheryl
Dickey and Esme Carmelo here
from the Office of Clinical
Programs and Pro Bono Programs.
Sheryl is a attorney
advisor, and Esme
is the faculty director of
HLAB, the Harvard Legal Aid
Bureau, which works with
students and low-income folks
with access to justice issues.
So with no further
ado, I'm going
to turn it over to Sheryl.
Thanks, Lisa.
I'm gonna see if I could
just leave this here.
Can folks see me if
I just stay seated?
Terrific.
So my name is Sheryl Dickey.
I'm an attorney advisor with the
Office of Clinical and Pro Bono
programs here at
Harvard Law School.
And for those of you who
are not from the law school,
a big part of our program are
clinical and pro bono programs.
Our clinics are
in-house clinics where
there are faculty supervisors'
offices here at the law school
representing clients on
a wide range of matters,
from housing to transactional
issues to cyber law issues.
And then we also
have a pro bono part
of our program involving student
practice organizations, where
we also have
practicing attorneys
who supervise students.
But the students do it on a
not-for-credit, and pro bono
basis.
Most Harvard Law
School students go
through one of our clinics
or our student practice
organizations.
Typically, it's
somewhere around 80%.
So one of the things that's
somewhat unique about Harvard
Law School is our students can
start practicing literally,
say, four to six weeks
after they arrive here
through our student
practice organizations.
You can't do a clinic until
you are a second year.
But as a first year, you can
participate and not-for-credit
basis in one of these
organizations where you're
actually representing clients.
And of course, you
always have supervision,
but that's a huge leap
when you first arrive here.
So one of the things that's
really been on our minds
through the Office of
Clinical and Pro Bono Programs
and through the clinical
faculty is, what can we
do to equip our
students so that they
are-- they have the tools
to do that work effectively?
And one key piece of
that is making sure
they understand their
ethical obligations
and that as student
attorneys, they
have an obligation to
know what the rules
of professional conduct are.
So the clinical faculty
had developed some content
to expose the students
to this material focused
on confidentiality,
conflicts, and competence.
And the rules are many, but
these are just three core
obligations to give
them a sense of what
it means to be an
attorney and what
they have to do to
comply with these rules
and to think about just the
fact that they're entering
this profession and now
have this obligation
and accountability
that they didn't have
six weeks before they arrived.
So we had, every year, an
online ethics tutorial.
And that-- excuse me,
we had a live session
that focused on these
three core concepts.
And the content was good.
It was focused on
these three principles
that we thought were critical
to convey to the students.
We had, typically,
three faculty members
who would volunteer
to do it every year.
But we would have, say, 200-plus
students in a room Friday
afternoon, restless, not
particularly thrilled
to be at a mandatory meeting.
The limitations of
a 200-person talk--
limited interactivity,
and for me,
the turning point where
I thought we really
need to be doing
something different
is where one year we
banned phones in the room.
Because everybody was on their
phone or on their laptops.
And then, a few people
brought phones anyway.
And so we had a conversation
afterwards, well,
what do we do about
those few people?
Do we intervene, interrupt?
And then, I think we
just stopped and looked
at each other and said,
what are we talking about?
This isn't working.
The students are on
their phone for a reason.
We can do better.
Is there something
else we could try
that would be more
on-demand, interactive,
something that we
don't know about
that we know is happening
elsewhere in the university
and there are people who
can help us figure this out?
So we had the right
content but bad format.
But we knew there was
a better way to do it.
So we started reaching out.
We reached out to the Ed School.
We wrote a grant to HILT, one
of the-- a grant proposal.
And we weren't funding.
But it started a conversation.
We had a valuable conversation
with the HILT team.
And it brought us to Lisa.
And that was the start of
that valuable partnership.
So today, I just wanted to
share a couple of reflections
with you on the different
type of partnerships
that we developed to
make this tutorial work.
And essentially, we had
those discrete partnerships
that Lisa talked about.
And those were critical.
But we also had ongoing working
relationships and working
partnerships, and I just
wanted to speak briefly
about two types of partnerships.
In terms of staff,
in order to make--
what I didn't know when we
first started out-- in order
to actually make
this tutorial work,
it involved so many different
entities to produce it,
to build it, to maintain it.
So for example, we worked
with media services
to do the videos.
We have worked
with Communications
to have photographs
to put in the videos.
We've worked for the
Harvard Training Portal
to host our actual--
our ethics tutorial.
We've worked with IT to
stream the videos that
go with the tutorial.
And all of those
discrete partnerships
have been invaluable.
And even with the
faculty members,
we had-- we've
worked with a broader
team of faculty members.
And we've had some
who have helped us out
with the street portions.
They have done a talk, say,
on conflicts of interest.
They prepared it.
We videoed them.
They reviewed it and
gave us comments,
and then, they were out.
And with all of those
partnerships, both on the staff
side and the
faculty side, people
brought expertise, a commitment
to quality, and follow through.
And that made that successful.
But the thing I was
thinking about--
what Lisa was touching on--
is these more substantive,
ongoing, working relationships
that we built with the library
and that we built with
a team of faculty,
with Professor Caramello being
one of the core faculty members
to really be this
ongoing working partner.
And what made the partnership
with the library work?
A lot of different things.
One is because of
that unique expertise
that the library
brought through Lisa.
There were so many
things that we
didn't know in terms
of basic things
around teaching and
learning, even developing,
for example, the videos.
We thought, we want to have
different faculty members
talking about different topics.
And I thought we'd just
videotape the faculty
and include it in the tutorial.
And she said, no, actually,
the research doesn't--
the research shows that
that's not the best way
to engage people.
People tune out
after two minutes.
The way you engage people
is you overlay photos,
you overlay text so
that yes, you see
the person at the beginning.
You see them at the end.
But you don't just make a
person watch a talking head.
So there were things
like that, that I
felt like Lisa just brought
value that ways that
didn't even know--
the things that we didn't know
in terms of making this better.
The library gave a deep,
long-term commitment
to the project in terms of
Lisa's time but also in terms
of just--
originally, it started
out, I think, as a product
that would last a year.
And frankly, it's gone on
for multiple years, which,
in addition to just that
commitment and time, Lisa
and the library brought drive
in terms of moving this forward.
Professor Caramello
and the faculty
are focused on
managing their clinics,
teaching, supervising,
representing clients.
They cannot be the main
drivers of a project from start
to finish, from streaming videos
to images to closed captions.
That can't be their role,
because they already
have many other hats
that they're wearing.
So the library
brought resources.
They were able to
tap into some funds
to allow us to do this
that we didn't have before.
And they brought adaptability.
This project had
fits and starts,
and it stalled at
different points.
But the library adapted
to those changes,
adapted to our schedules,
and made that work.
And as far as with the faculty--
and I will leave that to
Esme to talk more about.
But Esme, in particular,
gave us things
that we could only have from
a faculty member in terms
of deep subject
matter expertise,
not only in the law but also
the program and the messaging
that we wanted to
convey to students.
She and the team were very
flexible as our goals changed.
And it wasn't easy
as it butted up
against her other
commitments and obligations.
Faculty also brought a
deep level of understanding
of adult student learning.
And always, it was--
I think I was struck
by a focus on tone
as far as speaking to students
in a collegial manner,
not in a finger-wagging
ethics, do this,
or you're going
to be in trouble,
but in engaged, you are
entering a profession.
Let me speak to
you as a colleague.
And they really brought
that throughout in terms
of just that understanding
of how to speak to adults
and how to engage adults
in something along--
of this nature.
I'll leave it to
Professor Caramello
to speak of some
of the challenges.
But one of the things--
I think the biggest
challenge is you
don't know what you don't know.
And in terms of what
something like this
actually takes, how
much resources, people
it takes to get something
under the ground, what
it takes intensive
schedule, and that
impacted in terms of the
roles in which faculty played.
The last thing I want to
say is the role of students,
which I haven't talked about.
Students, essentially, have been
one of our discrete partners
in terms of they gave us
feedback on the live training.
This isn't working.
So we took that feedback, and
we tried something experimental
in doing this On
My Ethics tutorial.
We have an evaluation
built into the tutorial.
This semester, we're going
to be getting their feedback.
And the one question I have
after today's talks are,
is there a way that students
could play a different role,
not just as discrete partners
giving individual feedback
on a tutorial, but
maybe, for example, there
are students interested
in teaching and learning
who can provide other
kinds of feedback
to last in a more ongoing,
substantial basis, when
we know so many
students here are
going to go on to law teaching.
And perhaps it's a missed
opportunity to not engage them
in a more substantive way.
Professor Caramello?
Well, I'm more
comfortable standing,
so I'm just gonna
stand for a second.
You hit a lot of the things
that I was going to say.
And I think a big piece
of it is the whole,
you don't know what
you don't know.
And I think that's
one of the things that
interferes with the
formation of more
faculty-staff partnerships.
So I came to this--
I practice at the
Legal Aid Bureau.
I also teach a number of
classes at the law school.
I teach affordable
housing law and policy.
But I also teach professional
responsibility, which
is what we call legal ethics.
And I came to this as a lawyer.
I was a lawyer.
I was a practicing lawyer.
And I came here, and
I was very aware, very
humble about my
ability to teach.
I don't know what
teaching looks like.
I mean, I've been a
student, but that's it.
And I know there are all
these amazing resources.
I mean, I am at
Harvard University.
There's no question
that if anybody
has support for teaching,
it's this university.
But how in the
world do I use that?
And how do I access that?
What's even out there?
And my sense of what I
needed was also very diffuse.
So it wasn't like I
had an idea, and I just
needed to find the
right person who
could fulfill my needs with
this idea that was well
formed that I had.
So I think that's why I've
never really worked with Lisa
and others on my teaching.
And what was really
cool about this project
is that the project came to me.
So was involved in
the initial idea
to do this ethics tutorial.
But beyond that, the
idea of putting it
into an interactive
tutorial, I never
would have gone near
that with a 10-foot pole,
because that sounds
totally intimidating.
What if it's a failure?
I don't know.
It could be corny.
We brought it to the dean.
She's like, oh, sounds
really corny to me.
And so the whole guiding
principle in this whole thing
is not corny.
[LAUGHTER]
If it's not corny,
we have succeeded.
So it was really staff,
including Sheryl,
in the Office of Clinical
Programs; Lisa in the library,
forming those
relationships, making--
coming up with the idea
and then coming to us,
as faculty members, for our--
and what faculty member doesn't
like to be approached
with the, you
are such a brilliant
teacher of legal ethics.
You know so much about that.
What we need is
someone who really
knows the subject that you
really know and can convey it
beautifully.
So here is a camera.
And just show up and tell us
about the things you know.
So that's irresistible.
So of course, I
jumped in, as did
a number of other
faculty members, which
is also really cool.
And then, we're
working as a team,
and we all get to know
each other really well.
And we get to know
these guys really well.
But from that experience,
I have taken away--
I mean, I have sat
in Lisa's office
with this editing
software, where
she pulls out these
things and says,
what if we put
this overlay here?
And what if this
photo goes here?
And I'm going to
cut this, and I'm
going to make you talk
faster here and slower here.
And so I'm like aware of all
these tools that I never--
if Lisa said, would you
mind coming to my office,
and I'm going to show you
some editing software?
I would be like, no,
my 13-year-old son
tries to do that
every single night,
and I'm like, I'm not
going to look at that.
That's too boring.
But I got pulled in.
And so now as I'm going through
my teaching, I'm aware--
I'm thinking in a different
way about my own teaching.
I'm thinking, how can I--
what am I trying--
what's the kind of
education that would best
convey what I'm trying
to convey to the students
or best engage them in what
I'm trying to talk about?
And so now, I have exposure
to a whole new set of tools
and a whole new
set of people also.
But the goal is not just
for me to know Lisa's there,
for me to know Sheryl's
there, but rather
for me to know that the
different forms of teaching
are there and try and
think more creatively
and convey that to my
colleagues on the faculty.
So one challenge, I think--
because this felt so
different than what
I would have typically
expected to be
like faculty-student-- or
faculty-staff partnership
on a teaching
thing, was the roles
were not defined
at the beginning.
I think we all just were
creating this thing together.
And as a result, I
got very stressed.
And I think we all got
very stressed, because we
were like, who's is this?
Who owns it?
And by the end, we
sort of realized
that we needed to decide who
was the project manager, what
was Sheryl's role, what was
Lisa's role, what was my role.
And once we did all
of that, it felt good,
and I think that allowed
us each to just fully do
our piece knowing that's
what we were there for.
So I wish that we--
I think we all wish we
had had that conversation
at the beginning.
And one of the things-- once
we were having that role
definition conversation, and
then this is the last thing I
want to say--
Lisa-- I remember Lisa
saying, all right,
it's OK if this does not work.
That had not occurred to me.
It's OK if this is
bad and does not work,
because we are experimenting
with something like totally
new and different and cool.
And if we learn it doesn't work,
then we have learned something,
and it goes in the trash.
And no one ever wastes
four years on it again.
And if it does
work, that's great.
So I do think, not just as
a member of the faculty,
not just thinking like,
I have this problem,
this teaching problem,
and I want to solve it,
so I need to find the
right staff member who
can help me solve that--
but rather to think of
myself as a resource
and also to think about these
partnerships as opportunities
for experimentation to create
different kinds of teaching
and learning.
So thank you, guys,
so much for that.
[APPLAUSE]
No, you're such a great teacher.
And now we know that Lisa
has four years to spend
on any of your projects.
[LAUGHTER]
So I volunteer her.
But it will work.
So our second partnership
involves me and Dan Smail,
the Frank B. Baird Jr.
Professor of History
and the Chair of the
History Department.
You'd much rather hear
from him than from me.
So I'm just going to
say one minute of things
quickly about how the Bok
Center works with faculty.
Like any corny
motivational speaker,
I have two triads
I'm gonna run by you,
and the first one is the three
ways that we work with faculty.
The most traditional way
that we've done since 1975,
since our founding, is the
one-on-one consultation.
A faculty member
or any instructor,
graduate student
for that matter,
comes in with some
sort of question,
with a syllabus they
haven't tried before.
They're new to Harvard.
They wonder what Harvard
students are like.
They just need to talk
to someone for an hour
or for six hours.
We're happy to do that.
Our door is always open.
And a lot of
longer-term projects
are born out of those
one-off consultations.
So we do that often.
The second way is
a lot more intense.
It's through our learning lab.
So this is a group of--
well, it's a roving
swarm of people
at the Center of
the- the Bok Center
that has about five
permanent staff and any time,
40 to 70 undergraduate
fellows and about 10 to 12
graduate fellows at any time.
Basically, it's a
design and build studio.
So an instructor comes in
and says, I have a goal,
like teaching ethics,
or something like this.
We take a deep
dive into thinking
about lots of different
ways that you could do that.
We actually design three or
four prototypes of assignments,
and we give them to the 40 to 70
undergraduate student testers.
And we give them a
couple of readings,
so they kind of simulate
being in the class.
And they give us great feedback,
and not just basic feedback as,
well, this took me a long time.
Or this was hard.
But they work with us to
iterate that assignment.
So the first eight students
end up doing the same version.
We figure out it takes
too long, or there's
an opportunity we're
actually missing,
we want to add another
piece to the assignment.
Students 9 through 14
do that second version
of the assignment.
So it's a really great way
of working to give students
in the real class
something that's already
been tested in advance,
which we probably
do too rarely in higher ed.
And then, we have a
very strong commitment.
We don't foist on
instructors anything
that we don't support live.
So if students need
a hackathon to learn
how to do a little
bit of video editing
to complete the
assignment to learn where
to hold their iPhone to do
that podcast assignment,
we will run that hackathon
after hours with pizza
if we need to--
whatever it takes.
And then we have a commitment
to assessing, evaluating
how that thing worked at
the end, whether it worked,
whether it was a failure, what
it would need for the next go
around.
The third way we
work with faculty--
and this is a newer
thing for us--
is to take that learning
lab on the road, in a sense,
and to start doing
some residencies,
you might call them, with
programs or departments.
We've been doing this a
little bit more with gen ed
and also with the
history department,
just show up at a departmental
teaching retreat, for example,
with a little bit of research
on how that department looks
and works, especially from
the student perspective,
to try to work with the
critical mass of faculty
within that department to
help them think not just
about making their own course
good or three courses good,
but to think about how that
department can start to speak
a language that is kind
of in internal alignment
to students about
what they'll learn.
So that's my first triad.
My second one is
the three languages
we speak at the Bok Center.
One is evidence-based
pedagogy-- what
do studies of student
learning, psych studies,
cognitive psych studies tell us
about how students learn well?
This really works
for faculty coming
from quantitative disciplines
who want to see a graph.
And we believe firmly in
that and speak that language.
The other way, though--
some faculty come
from disciplines
that think that
psychology is just
another discipline
in William James Hall
and that their own discipline
has really deeply sedimented
knowledge about how
knowledge is structured,
about how students move from
being a novice to an expert.
So for them, we
speak the language
of disciplinary expertise.
Here's a sociologist.
This is the three or four--
these are the three
or four things
that are probably really
important to that person
that there are
really characteristic
of that discipline.
How can we get them to
make those things more
transparent to students
by talking with us?
And the third language we speak
is the language of analogy.
Right Faculty comes and
says, my group activities
aren't working very well.
Rather than reinvent
the wheel, we
can actually look at places
in the real world outside
of Harvard where group work--
groups work effectively,
where it's crucial
that bridge stand because the
engineers worked well together.
And so we try to bring that
into the classroom as well.
Anyway, that's the
less interesting part.
The more interesting part
is what a real life faculty
member thinks of all this.
Well, thank you, Adam.
And thanks to
everyone for coming.
It's just wonderful
to see you all here.
I wanted to follow very much
in the line of what Esme said
and just give you
a sense of what
it's been like from my
perspective to have a chance
to work with people like Adam
and his team members at the Bok
Center.
If you don't mind,
I'd like to begin
with a couple of
stories of things
that I've used in the classroom.
I graduated in 1994 and
moved out into teaching.
And like most people,
I was thrown out there
with very little support at all.
One of the stories I used to
tell to my medieval history
class--
the learning objective
was to get students
to try to understand
the power of the horse
people of the Asian steppes.
And so I told them a story about
what a wonderful thing a horse
was.
Because when you're
traveling, it's
not only mode of transport.
But you can milk the
mares to get milk.
You can take blood out from
the horse in an emergency
and use it as nourishment.
You can store them in
the sacks of stomachs
for a long, long period of time.
You can press the
meat that you might
have between the saddle
and the horse flesh.
And it kind of gets impregnated
with the sweat of the horse.
And it's a beautiful,
tasty treat
that lasts a long, long time.
The other story
I would tell them
was that was a totally
apocryphal story
about a famous viking who was
called "the children's man."
And the reason he
got this reputation
is that unlike
the other vikings,
he did not like to play
in the game where--
when you were
pillaging a settlement,
you would find a baby and
throw it up in the air
and see if you could catch it
on the point of your spear.
Now--
[LAUGHTER]
--before I go any further
with this, do any of you
have any experiences of
revulsion to these stories?
Not yet.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, I don't do this anymore.
I haven't used these stories
for at least 12 years
for reasons that I'll
explain in just a moment.
When I first began
teaching, I taught
by trial and error, which
meant I tried a lot,
and I made a lot of errors.
But one of the things I figured
out over a few years is--
this is something Gary King said
about emotional experience--
students learn really
well when something
happens inside their
bodies, when they
have an embodied experience.
And I figured that out.
And I used these deliberately
to disgust people,
because it worked.
It got their attention.
They snapped into focus.
And then I would move
on to other things.
And I would drop one of these
things every 10 or 15 minutes.
So that was something
that was really--
I found really interesting.
Now, this brings me to the point
of the first set of remarks
is that there is an enormous
body of pedagogical work--
research out there that already
knew, or has soon learned,
what I figured out on my own.
And one of the great revelations
of having a chance to actually
get--
touch this experience
is that this is not
just K-12 research,
which is what I thought
it was back in the 1990s.
This is stuff that
works on my students.
And this has been a
real revelation for me.
So things like this, I
actually learned about.
This embodied
education is something
that I worked out for myself.
I wouldn't have had to go
through all of the trial
and error to figure
this out if I'd
been able to work
with someone who
was an expert in that field.
And then the second
point I'm going to make
is that students change.
The reason I don't
use these stories
anymore is the trigger
warning phenomenon.
This is too much for students.
I now do different things to
get them to move and experience
in some ways.
Various forms of active
and interactive learning,
for example, are the
kinds of things I use now.
And I'm relying on experts who
know these kinds of things.
Because there's so
many opportunities
out there to learn that I want--
know just want to pick up.
So let me fast forward to the
other brief set of remarks
I wanted to make,
which really has to do
with collaborative teaching.
And when I do research
now, all of my research,
in some form or another,
is collaborative.
I have-- I do it laterally.
I work with peers and colleagues
in fields that I don't know.
And I rely on them
and their knowledge
to help me get to do
what I want to do.
I also do generational
kinds of learning.
I work with my former
graduate students.
I work with my
I work with my undergraduates.
And we are all
researching together not
just because they're
working for me,
but because they can bring
expertise to the table
that I don't have.
And it vastly improves
all the things
that we can do as
a research group.
This applies
directly to teaching.
And this, for me, has been
one of the great revelations,
is that I don't have
to teach all by myself.
For me, this happened
in 2012 when I first
began teaching a really active
learning-based type of course.
This is in the context
of what soon became
with Ann Blair, the
digital teaching fellow
program for which we got
fantastic HILT support.
And one of things
I discovered is
that I can use my students,
the graduate students that I'm
working with, to
help me figure out
how to teach better
and in particular,
how to bring things like--
Sheryl mentioned
phones in classrooms.
How could I teach a class
where the computer's not banned
but is an integral part of the
way in which the students are
doing it?
And we did a lot-- we worked
on a lot of things, again,
a lot of trial and error.
But we learned a number
of amazing things
about things that work
well in classrooms.
This is exactly
the kinds of things
that we are now building up
in the history department
working very closely--
Adam mentioned the teaching
retreat we had earlier.
We're working with
the Bok Center
to try to build up
all these resources.
It's particularly important
as everyone shifts--
is going to be shifting
to the 75-minute teaching.
Well, no one--no student wants
to sit there for 75 minutes
at a lecture.
So what do we put in the
middle of the classes?
There's lots and lots of faculty
in the history department
who want to know the
answer to that question.
I'm sure that's true elsewhere.
And then here's
finally just a coda--
I was thinking about your
caddies and the pit crew.
I really love the
idea of partnerships.
I don't know if any
of you have seen
the research or
the comments that
have been made about the
growth of credits in movies.
Have any of you ever
gone to the-- watched
the end of The Lord of
the Rings, the third one?
It goes on and on.
You eventually
get the whole crew
of people who have been fans.
Gandalf the Grey
figure's in there
if you're willing to
wait 20 minutes for it.
But also, the growth of
acknowledgments in books--
we now realize that authorship
is a community project.
And we can't do it, in
the case of teaching,
without our partners.
[APPLAUSE]
We only have about 20
minutes left in the session.
And we want to
give you the chance
to talk more to the
faculty and elaborate
on these asked
questions and so on.
But we also want
you to have a chance
to do this activity
that we've set out.
So if you look on
your table, everyone
should have enough copies
of this large worksheet.
You can fold and take it
with you if you'd like.
Basically, you can see there's
a faculty side and a staff side.
The idea is to
use this worksheet
as a kind of brainstorming
opportunity to think about
whether you are on the
faculty side or the staff
side of this chart.
The worksheet kind
of prompts you
to answer a bunch of questions.
[CHATTER]
Obviously, there are a bunch
of questions to think through--
again, not what kind of products
and services can you offer
or what kinds of
things concretely
do you necessarily need, but
what kinds of experiments would
you like to conduct?
What are the things
that, maybe, you offer?
Say that the library
offers study space,
but that's not unique
to the library.
But there are some things
that the library offers
that are unique to
the library, and how
you might talk about and
think about internally
what you want to get out of
those things that you offer,
or as a faculty
member, that you seek.
How long you'd like to do them--
if you'd like to enter into
one of these partnerships,
are you committing yourself
for the next 50 years
to supporting this kind
of student learning,
or is it something that
you're hoping to build once
and then will be
self-sustaining?
So we thought we'd give you
about 12 minutes or something
to start filling out your
side of the worksheet,
or if you're adventurous,
both sides of the worksheet.
We hope that tables have some
mixing of faculty and staff
who can talk with each other.
And then, we'll share
out with the group
what we've discovered, some
great answers that came out
of here so that you can
think about your roles
with some clarity and what
you have to offer each other.
And if our faculty
volunteers don't mind,
we can circulate through
the room sort of like people
at a wedding and drop
in on your tables
and ask you how the filet mignon
is and things and chat with you
as you work.
All right?
[CHATTER]
OK, I think we're gonna start to
wrap up and think about like--
do you have-- as you're
having your conversations,
I think one of the things
I would like to see
is, what-- do you have any
questions for the faculty here
or the staff here about
what we were talking about,
and observations about
filling out the form,
or just thinking about
filling out the form?
Yes.
I just wanted to share some
of the learnings from us.
It prompted a conversation
about our vis-a-vis students.
Do we have access?
Do we work through faculty?
And then because
some of us teach
in exec ed or
part-time learners,
the access questions
that you asked
are very different for
our different learners
in different programs
and at different levels.
So I actually posed a question
that I've been thinking
a lot on, which is maybe not--
it's a little off
the slide over here.
And it's there the relationship
between staff and faculty
in learning from each other.
Faculty are staff.
Staff are not faculty.
And we're often tracked in
terms of our development
and our productivity
and our goals
that we achieve for
the university in very
different ways and for very
specific and important reasons.
But at some point,
there will be an overlap
between, I could do my
job so much better if I
had a relationship or had
access to a faculty member,
some other part
of the university
that I could then
take that information
and help a faculty
member at the University.
So it's this circular motion how
are we helping faculty develop
new skills that they can
learn from staff to make
their teaching better?
But how is staff are using and
being helped along the path
to gain insight and knowledge
from incredible, incredible
faculty to help them do their
jobs better to help incredible,
incredible faculty?
And so it's that kind of--
where are the projects
that are successful?
And how is that being used for
staff performance development
and staff learning goals.
So as a staff member,
I'm incredibly
lucky to work at
a university that
cares about so many things, but
I'm also developing as a person
as well.
And so how do we make successful
relationships with projects
that work for faculty and then
how do we keep those in step
with a staff member's personal
professional development?
And so those are the kind
of questions that I have.
How do we build that in?
And how do managers and
faculty think about that or HRs
think about that?
So you're saying giving
staff more access to faculty
in other parts of the
university as part
of a professional development.
In one way, this conference
is a really good example
of that and one of the
few-- we were talking
about the few examples where
staff and faculty actually
get together in sort
of a non-work way.
I think that is
really important.
Do you guys have any
comments about any of that,
her access to faculty or?
Well, actually, I thought
your comments were fantastic.
I think all I would add
from a faculty point of view
is that one of the things
I really value about staff
is that the staff are often, as
important nodes in a network,
are some of the major conduits
for the flow of information
laterally.
And therefore, we
rely on them, which
I think also means that we like
that position to grow and build
and connect.
And from my point
of view, I recognize
that that should happen.
It is rewarding if it
does happen in that way.
It really has to
do with something
I know Peter's been concerned
about for a lot of time, which
is, how do we get
news to travel?
It doesn't necessarily
want to travel easily.
I don't tell people
about sweaty horse meet,
but I talk about zombies.
Because I say, we feed
on the brains of faculty.
I trick every faculty
member into giving me
a grand seminar in whatever
their courses before I
figure out how to help them.
This is a great way to do it.
So is that how
[INAUDIBLE] starts?
[LAUGHTER]
So over the years, I've
benefited enormously,
enormously from ATG, from
Bill's help for many years,
from the Center for
Geographic Analysis and so on.
But when it-- that
was sort of things
that I could use in a class.
But when it came to transforming
the class as we moved
from electric class to a blended
learning to a flip model,
we didn't have any guidance,
particularly, or help.
We just thought we
knew how to do it.
And as I was saying
the earlier panel,
it was a pretty bad experience.
The students walked.
They were unhappy and so.
My question for you is--
for all-- for people
and Adam is, well,
if one really undertakes
a major experiment
in trying to transform a
major educational experience,
how long does it take?
And how do we sustain--
I understand that we can
sustain staff commitment
to some extent, to
a greater extent.
How do we sustain
faculty commitment?
Well, for this particular
project, the Ethics 101--
Student Attorneys
is what it's called.
It is an hour-long through
tutorial, online tutorial.
And it's not a small thing.
And it took a lot of
really deep thought
to think about how to transform
the in-person to the online
and to do it in the right way.
For me, I think there were
a lot of stops and stars.
And I just felt like this was
the best option for the goals
that they had stated.
And I was really going to
keep going until we got there,
because I just felt we
needed some kind of artifact
on which to decide
whether this truly
is better than the
in-person or better
than some other kinds of model.
We couldn't ever really tell
until we got the artifact,
so I just kept pushing
until we got there.
And we're very, very close.
We're like a week away.
As far as how to maintain
faculty interest--
Uh-oh.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I do think
that it's what Sheryl
was saying about the drive--
a lot of the drive coming
from Lisa and from Sheryl--
it's very true
that I kept feeling
like I was being pulled in.
And I just had a sense of
like, I made this commitment,
and I've come this far.
But I'm so glad--
so now looking back
on it, I would not
worry about it taking so long.
But I also feel like part of
the resistance is we have to--
as faculty, I see other kinds
of innovations we're making,
including around implicit
bias in the classroom
and other things.
And there's just a
really steep hill
to climb to persuade
faculty that the teaching
methods they're using are
not the best ones out there
or that the thing--
the specific thing that you're
proposing that's going to take
a long time for them to learn
and implement successfully
and may be a failure-- it
may not be the right thing--
to persuade them that
that's worth trying
and that it's better,
that specific thing
is better than the specific
thing they're doing.
Because I can recognize
that what I'm doing
might not be 100%
the best thing.
But how do I know that
what you're proposing
is even better?
So am I going to read
all the literature?
And so it's partly
sustaining the interest,
but it's partly just
the initial inertia.
So I assume that what
you're doing already
is getting people who
have taken the plunge
and sending them on the
road to say, I loved this,
and here's how my
classroom works better.
And I think Harvard
Magazine and other places
have done a great
job of spotlighting--
shining a spotlight on
specific teaching innovations,
including flipped classrooms
and having boosters.
And then, you get a little
bored teaching the same thing
the same way over time.
And so having these
opportunities to be led down
a different path
and not just have
to walk down it
on your own is, I
think, the great thing
about being here.
I am keenly aware that
we are the only thing
standing between you and lunch,
and that is a terrible position
in which to be.
I'll enjoy the power
for one second.
All right, now, I think
it's time for lunch.
Let me just thank
my fellow panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
And of course, thanks
to the HILT, the most
magnificent conference.
And thanks to all
of you for coming.
So enjoy the lunch.